what I want to do in this video is try
to get a good understanding of how the
US federal income tax rate schedule
works and also what people mean when
they say tax brackets or what does it
mean to be in a tax bracket so let's say
that I make a hundred thousand dollars
and I'm single and I'm not going to go
into the deductions or anything fancy
like that so let's say I make one
hundred thousand dollars in a given year
and these numbers will change as the tax
code changes but the general idea is the
same thing although the details might
change so the way the rate schedule
works is that the first
8350 of my hundred thousand dollars will
be taxed at 10% so the first eight
thousand three hundred fifty dollars
will be taxed at 10% so I'll be paying
what that's pretty easy to calculate
I'll pay eight hundred and thirty five
dollars on that first on that first
eight thousand three hundred and fifty
dollars now the next twenty five
thousand six hundred or the next from
eight thousand three hundred fifty two
thirty three thousand nine hundred and
fifty that will be taxed at 15 percent
that will be taxed at 15 percent so this
amount right over here I will have to
pay fifteen percent on that and so that
the difference between thirty three
thousand nine hundred fifty and eight
thousand three hundred fifty is twenty
six thousand twenty-five thousand six
hundred so it's twenty-five thousand six
hundred times fifteen percent I'll
calculate it all at the end using a
calculator
now the next forty eight thousand three
hundred dollars is going to be taxed at
twenty five percent so let me draw that
over here so the next this next slug
right over here is going to be taxed at
25 percent so this is the difference
between eighty two thousand two hundred
fifty and thirty three thousand nine
hundred fifty that's forty eight
thousand three hundred so it's going to
be forty eight thousand three hundred
times twenty five percent and then
finally the remainder the amount above
eighty two fifty since I don't get into
the next bracket above that this part
right here is going to be taxed at 28%
so this part right over here is going to
be taxed at 28% let me get my trusty
calculator out
figure out what that is so if that's
going to be taxed debt so the difference
between a hundred thousand dollars in
eight eighty two thousand two fifty so
one hundred one hundred thousand dollars
minus eighty to two fifty is seventeen
thousand seven hundred and fifty so it
is seventeen thousand seven hundred and
fifty times twenty eight percent and now
I could use the calculator to calculate
all of these so it's going to be let's
do it all at once seventeen thousand
seven hundred and fifty times twenty
eight percent so let's say that it's
point two eight plus forty eight
thousand three hundred forty eight
thousand three hundred times twenty-five
percent 0.25 plus twenty five thousand
six hundred twenty-five thousand six
hundred times fifteen percent point one
five finally plus eight hundred and
thirty-five dollars plus eight hundred
and thirty-five dollars I'm going to pay
twenty one thousand seven hundred and
twenty dollars so this the sum of all of
these in total I'm going to pay twenty
one thousand already forgot the number
twenty one thousand seven hundred seven
hundred and twenty dollars and I want to
make sure you don't have the
misconception notice you only pay the
twenty eight percent on the incremental
amount when you enter that bracket you
don't pay this twenty-eight percent on
the entire hundred thousand dollars just
on the increment above eighty two fifty
you don't pay the twenty-five percent on
the entire amount just on the increment
between 33 and eighty-two